Game of Thrones season 6 episode 4 is
out let's have a look at the wall john
tells ed he's going to go south and get
warm which seems pretty fair after the
[ __ ] John's been through he's been
attacked by zombies torn up by an eagle
shot by his lover strangled by a thin
stabbed by Karl Tanner beat up by
walkers and finally [ __ ] murdered by
his own men so if anyone deserves a
holiday it's John but the vacation is
delayed when Brienne pod and Sansa
arrive at Castle black John and Sansa
haven't seen each other since season 1
in fact we've never even seen them talk
to each other in the show or books till
now because they were never really close
Sansa was always the Lady of doing
ladylike things while John was ever the
bastard and outsider moping in the
shadows but now after all their family
has been through their relationship
means so much so it's beautiful to see
the two unite anyway Sansa wants to
retake Winterfell and wreck Ramsay's
[ __ ] up though John is reluctant for now
but by the way does censer know that
john died and was resurrected is he not
going to bring that up Sansa has so far
been separated from the supernatural in
this series so it'll be interesting to
see how she reacts when she finds out
that a half-brother is a zombie anyway
Davos Melisandre and Brienne meet and
quickly establish that they've all got
beef with each other
Melisandre used blood magic to kill
Renly Baratheon who Brienne loved
Brienne killed Stannis Baratheon who
Davos and Mel were loyal to and though
Davos doesn't yet know it Melbourne
Shireen who Davos loved like a daughter
so basically all these guys have reasons
to hate each other which could possibly
lead to conflict in the future down in
the Vale we see Robin Arryn son of Lysa
Arryn who Littlefinger murdered a couple
of seasons ago and of Jon Arryn who
Littlefinger convinced Lysa to murder
before that Robin has spent a season in
the care of Yan Royce but that doesn't
seem prove made him a better warrior he
should have done a training montage like
ire Yan Royce is actually kind of a cool
character in the books he's called
bronze eon for the ancient bronze armor
he wears engraved with magic runes his
son roba joins Renly Baratheon's
Kingsguard and ends up killed by Loras
in a rage after Renly's death and yawns
third son is Waymar The Watchmen from
season 1 episode 1 who's killed by a
white Walker anyway Royce's little
fingers biggest political opponent in
the Vale so when Littlefinger turns up
yawns all like
I think you gave sensor to the Bolton's
so little fingers all like I think you
gave Sansa to the Bolton's of course Yan
is right but Lord bro Burnside's with
little finger because Peter keeps
buttering him up with these gifts so
long as Robin is on the little fingers
thumb there isn't much the Lords of the
Vale can do against him the Falcon is
the sigil of house Aaron so this caged
falcon could symbolize little fingers
control of the veil also little finger
set is going to use the Knights of the
Vale against the Bolton's to get back
Sansa so these guys could be
instrumental in the upcoming battle for
Winterfell in the latest installment of
one girl two eunuchs on a dwarf tyrion
negotiates a peace with the cities of
slavers Bay by allowing them to slowly
phase out slavery instead of straight-up
banning it as Danny wanted of course
this upsets the ex-slaves including grey
worm is sandy and the freedmen of
moraine but tyrion argues that they have
to make some kind of deal or the whole
situation will fall apart which is a
great illustration of how politics works
right it's easy to say let's bring peace
and justice for all but sometimes that's
not possible sometimes you got to
compromise you got to choose between two
evils it's like how John decided to
bring wildlings south of the wall that
did threaten the watch and broke their
traditions and values but it was
necessary to stop the White Walkers
growing stronger all that said as clever
as Tyrion maybe he doesn't really know
what he's talking about here right like
grey worm says Tyrion doesn't know the
cultures of slavers Bay nor does he know
the true horror of being a slave so even
if he's right that they've got a
compromise he may be overconfident here
the uneasy peace may not last meanwhile
the super Daario brothers tracked an
heiress to Vaes Dothrak Daario sees
Joris greyscale and jurors like nah
don't worry about this highly contagious
incurable fatal disease that turns you
into a zombie
it'll be fine no doubt Daario will be
looking for an opportunity to put Jorah
down because really that stuff could
spread and a grey plague is the last
thing anyone needs right now
anyway Jorah and Daario go on a super
sneaky mission to rescue Durning in Vaes
Dothrak and it doesn't go very well
Jorah seems to be a bit rusty in combat
maybe the spreading stone is slowing him
and Daario splatters a body with a rock
because stealth Dany sits through a
lecture from the - Colleen makes a
friend heads out meets Jorah and Daario
and
visors a plan in King's Landing Marjorie
is still with the sparrows and she's
looking real fine for someone who's been
pooping in a bucket for weeks she meets
with a high Sparrow who tries to win her
over with a speech about the moral
emptiness of Westerosi materialism he
seems to be speaking from the heart but
it doesn't convince Marge Marge gets to
meet with her brother Loras and Loras is
a wreck desperate to get out of his
dungeon though he's still probably
better off than where is out in the
books in dance so she sends Loras to
retake dragons turn when he gets
deep-fried by a pot of boiling oil at
least we're told that's what happened
some fans believe that's a lie and that
he's secretly fine but anyway Tommen
meets his mother and seems a bit torn
between Cersei and the high Sparrow who
he had that lovely chat with last
episode Tommen then tells Cersei a
seeker that the high Sparrow told him
and the secret seems to be that the
sparrows planning a walk of shame for
Marg because that's what Cersei then
tells Alayna
and Kevin she convinces them to use a
Tyrell army to take out the high Sparrow
Elena agrees because she wants to free
her grandchildren margin Loras and Kevin
agreed in the hope of getting back his
son Lancel the dopey kid with the funny
hat from season one who was wounded at
the Blackwater and ended up joining the
sparrows by the way Jamie doesn't seem
to know that Cersei had an affair with
Lancel maybe he'll find out and break up
with her anyway all agree to take out
the Sparrow with force and from the
looks of these shots from the trailer it
looks like the Tyrells will have no
trouble overwhelming the sparrows or
could there be more going on here we
know that the sparrow is good at
manipulating Tommen maybe he told Tom
and his plans for Margaery knowing that
Tommen would tell Cersei and knowing
that Cersei would respond with force
maybe this is all part of the sparrows
plan and he's got something special up
his sleeve to deal with the soldiers
will have to wait and see
meanwhile Theon Greyjoy returns to the
Iron Islands last time he came he was a
swaggering over proud douche bird now
he's a broken man the tragedy of Theon
is that all he ever really wanted was a
family he was born a Greyjoy of Pike but
after the Greyjoy rebellion he was taken
as a sort of a hostage by the Starks
edad treated him kindly but he never
felt truly accepted which led him to
betray the Starks for the Greyjoy's but
then he found he wasn't accepted by them
either Theon has done terrible things
but
only to be loved and of course no one
deserves the torture that he suffered at
Ramsey's hands so all this just makes it
sadder that his sister's so mad with him
for his terrible choices and for wasting
her men in that failed rescue attempt in
season 4
at first she thinks Theon now wants to
claim the sea stone chair but Theon says
he wants to support Yara in her claim to
the throne of the Iron Islands it's not
clear how Theon could help because the
iron men respect strength and Theon is
not strong right now so we'll have to
see how that goes either way we've got a
king's mood coming an election of the
new ruler of the Ironborn Assurant Euron
both have awesome speeches in this
chapter of the book hopefully some of
that will make it into the show anyway
at Winterfell Ramsay tries to be
intimidating but OSHA brings the SAS
pointing out that while he may flee
people at least he doesn't eat them like
the thins do beyond the wall OSHA tries
to seduce Ramsay mere tactic she's used
before and for a moment it looks like
she might kill him but round he's
playing her he knows she helped trick
one escaped Winterfell before so he
kills her then keeps on peeling his
Apple the death of OSHA is further
evidence that the umbers giving Rickon
to Ramsay probably isn't part of any
northern conspiracy and if it is the
plans already going badly back at the
wall edie john torment pod Brienne and
Sansa have brunch Tommen takes a fancy
to Brienne which is adorable and then a
Bolton man arrives with a letter from
Ramsay demanding Sansa and threatening
all manner of violence and rape and
awfulness in the books this letter is
known as the pink letter it arrives
before John's death and there's lots of
mystery surrounding it like some readers
believe it was actually written by mance
rayder
who is still alive in the books but in
the show it seems more straightforward
it's pretty clear that the letter was
written by Ramsay and delivered by a
Bolton man so Sansa urges Jon to ride
south with the wildlings to save Rickon
and Winterfell the numbers aren't good
Ramsay apparently has 5000 men while
there are only 2,000 fighting wildlings
but it sounds suggests that they ask the
loyal northern houses for help so maybe
Davos will be sent to white Harbor like
in the books and also we know these
Knights of the Vale are on their way so
this is all laying the groundwork for a
truly massive battle that some fans are
calling bastard Bowl back at Vaes
Dothrak
only stands before the Dothraki calls
the leaders of all the thousands and
thousands of dollar a key in the city
Danny gives a speech about how awesome
she is which is just kind of what she
does and the Dothraki threaten rape
which is just kind of what they do so
Danny bones down the temple with the
carl's and herself trapped inside then
dramatically emerges from the flames
unharmed and all the Dothraki bell down
at her feet along like the end of season
one when Danny rises from a pyre with a
dragons this scene seems to confirm that
in the show Daenerys is immune to fire
in the books she is not Danny gets
burned in dance and the author George
modern said that the season 1 thing was
a one-off magic miracle type thing but
either way what's interesting about this
scene is what it means for Danny as a
character this is a fulfillment of
quoits words that to go forward Daenerys
must go back Danny has gone back to the
Dothraki back to her birth as the
unburnt back to violence and fire and
blood she spent so long compromising
chaining her dragons trying to
peacefully rule foreign cities this is a
return to her roots back to being a
dragon queen which raises the question
what was the point of the last few
seasons if she's just going back to
where she started what's the point of a
character arc that loops back to where
it began there needs to be change right
maybe Daenerys will change by going even
further in the direction of violence
than she ever has before maybe she'll
burn down the cities of slavers Bay cut
a bloody path across a source and arrive
at Westeros not as a savior but as an
invader with a horde of Dothraki
barbarians and for insell sorts a mad
tyrant just like a father the Mad King
either way we've now had birth John and
Danny reborn this season John from ice
and Danny from fire they both have
followers thinking there's some kind of
God they both have red priests saying
there's or 'hi or the prince that was
promised the savior of the world however
this story ends Dany and John will be at
its center thanks for watching
special thanks to all the translators
who have been translating captions for
these videos into Spanish Arabic German
Russian French and more your work is
very much appreciated if you'd like to
help there's a link in the description
thanks also to all the patrons
supporting this channel on patreon
including Melanie Williams ooh
monster Jeanne Debbie loo Kate Lyons
Jeff Franz Leatherwood sunk 52 frames
Aden Braddock Lange Cornelius Cobell
carafe Elia Sanchez eco shining force -
Brett gamble Mike Fox Kelly Theobald
Pembridge a full Brantly and Brent
Cheers
you